having a movie made about your life
might seem like a modern dream but for
those who've watched their stories play
on the big screen it can sometimes be a
nightmare for these real-life people who
were depicted in movies the experience
of becoming film famous was not all it
was cracked up to be
here's why Moneyball if you're
unfamiliar with the story of Moneyball
it's a retelling of how Oakland
Athletics general manager Billy Beane
reshaped the way professional baseball
scouts and front office's put together a
competitive roster the movie was
critically acclaimed but Oakland's
real-life manager art Howe was not
pleased with what he saw how was
portrayed in the movie by Philip Seymour
Hoffman and while Hoffman may have been
an oscar-winning prestige actor how
thought he was too hefty to play him
that was the smallest of his concerns
with the depiction how also took issue
with the fact that he was represented as
little more than an old school baseball
dinosaur was being lapped by brilliant
minds like being he even called a movie
character assassination saying people
who don't know me are going to think
that's how I was you work to build a
reputation and then in two hours this
movie breaks it down he was also less
than impressed with the movie's
attention to players on-base percentages
because in his words that was a dumb
moment no seriously that is the
blindside for Baltimore Ravens offensive
lineman Michael Oher all the buzz that
followed his betrayal in the blindside
was a bit infuriating while it was true
that the two E's took him in and have
since become his family the movie made
it seem as though he was a gentle giant
with protective instincts whom Sandra
Bullock guided into getting good at
football but in real life he'd been
playing football for years before he was
brought into the to e crew as he told
NPR I could not figure out why the
director chose to show me as someone who
had to be taught the game of football
whether it was SJ moving around ketchup
bottles or leanne explaining to me what
blocking is about i watched those scenes
thinking no that's not me at all i've
been studying really studying the game
since i was a kid that was my main
hang-up with the film Millar right then
all eyes on me
this biopic of Tupac Shakur was a
critical miss for several reasons not
the least of which was how the movie
recreated Jada Pinkett Smith's
involvement in his life story
the actress skewered the film on Twitter
and accused the filmmakers of
fabricating a scene wherein Shakur read
her a poem and claimed they completely
invented a farewell between the two
she also denied the occurrence of an
argument portrayed in the film calling
the movies version of events deeply
hurtful Sully
it's a scientific fact that everybody
loves Tom Hanks and the man he portrays
in 2016 Sully is a bona fide hero
captain Chesley Sullenberger the third
was the pilot who pulled off the miracle
on the Hudson so named because it was
one of the most insane emergency
landings ever attempted and saved every
person onboard the plane but if the
film's plot had been true to the actual
events it would have been over in half
an hour because all that time spent
investigating whether or not he'd done
the right thing was greatly exaggerated
there was never any significant doubt as
to whether selling made the right call
the first set of simulations shown in
the film to constitute damning evidence
that the emergency landing was
unnecessary showed just the opposite and
the final report praised both Sully and
the crew for their heroism the real
investigators were none too happy about
this accusing director Clint Eastwood of
making manufactured villains out of them
for the sake of dramatic tension now
retired lead investigator Robert Benson
complained that the film had hurt his
reputation while putting its level of
realism somewhere between sharknado 2
and sharknado 3 spotlight in an age
where news outlets consistently get
accused of alleged bias and fakery
spotlight provides a noble portrait of
journalistic courage and integrity the
oscar-winning movie revisited how the
Boston Globe exposed heinous sexual
abuse and a dastardly cover-up by the
Catholic Church so a picture this
serious might seem to demand a standard
of truth seeking worthy of the
journalists it represents however one of
the real-life people depicted in the
movie was more than mildly offended as
to how he came off in the pic school
representative Jack Dunne was painted as
a morally ambiguous figure who tried to
excuse away abuses it's a big school
Robbie you know that and then we're
talking about seven alleged victims over
what eight years the real done
subsequently sued the studio for
defamation and ultimately the filmmakers
apologize to him and settle for an
undisclosed sum
you